dans l'actualité politique les élections
législatives approchent les électeurs
éliront leurs députés les 12 et 19 juin
prochain tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir
plus clair et vous dresse les enjeux du
scrutin dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines ce soir
direction la 2e circonscription avec
célia gars de saint gobain soir de la
rédaction de tv 78 quelles sont les
communes déjà concernés par cette
circonscription alors on l'appelle
versailles chevreuse de cette
circonscription est située au sud est du
département vous l'aurez compris elle
englobe le sud de versailles les villes
de chevreuse choisel bucs magny les
hameaux viroflay ou encore
vélizy-villacoublay
depuis 2010 est c'est le député le
député de cette circonscription c'est
jean-noël barrot candidats en marche et
qui sera de nouveau investi en 2022 sous
la bannière ensemble regroupant et les
partis de la majorité présidentielle
un des buts et qui n'est pas issu des
rangs de la droite une première sous la
vème république
valérie pécresse a été élu en 2002 2007
et 2012 lors des élections partielles de
2016 c'est son suppléant pascal thévenot
mer les républicains de
vélizy-villacoublay qui a été très
largement élu avec 72 25 % des suffrages
exprimés c'est donc une petite surprise
lorsque jean noël barrot membre du modem
est en tête en 2017 au second tour avec
58 bien que 3% des voix contre pascal
thévenot avec 41,7 pour se retrouver
pour cette élection 2022 on prend un peu
les mêmes et on recommence un peu un bis
repetita by très vite repetita oui pour
les deux candidats de 2010 est du second
tour improbable match retour se dessine
jean-noël barrot devra défendre son
mandat pour l'emporter une seconde fois
si l'on prend les résultats du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron est en tête avec 33% des
voix à versailles contre 14% pour
valérie pécresse arrivée quatrième
derrière jean-luc mélenchon emmanuel
macron est également devant avec 38% à
viroflay 32% à vélizy villacoublay et
37% à chevreuse et si on met de côté ses
deux candidats le casting change pour
les autres partis oui marc soriano de la
france insoumise qui était arrivé
troisième en 2 17 ne sera pas au casting
cette année avec eux la nouvelle
alliance de la gauche baptisé 1 us
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale c'est une candidate europe
ecologie les verts maïté qu'arrive b
doit ni qui est investi habitante de
viroflay depuis 30 ans elle a annoncé
qu'elle fera campagne à vélo avec une
son suppléant pour le rassemblement
national ce sera gaëtan bros il a été
candidat pour les départementales dans
le canton de montigny le bretonneux en
juin 2021 mais d'autres candidats
continuent sont encore en lice même si
le fond de faibles scores comme le
céline julier étiqueté extrême droite en
2017 elle avait tout juste dépasser les
1% lors des dernières législatives elle
retente sa chance cette fois-ci sous la
bannière reconquête le parti et d'eric
zemmour qui a fait d'assez au bon score
à la dernière présidentielle dans les
communes concernées jérémy et bizet du
rassemblement des écologistes de la
droite et du centre se représente une
troisième fois né à chevreuse et vivent
maintenant à jouy en josas il a
rassemblé pour les deux dernières
élections les élections moins de 2% des
suffrages exprimés deux autres
candidates ont aussi à déclarer leur
participation aux législatives
il s'agit de clara ferrer pour le parti
animalistes et de hélène janis et pour
lui ouvrir toutes les informations sur
cette 2e circonscription des yvelines on
rappelle les dates 1 12 et 19 juin pour
ces élections législatives merci sega
400 go